How's it goin bros! And welcome back to another episode of skrattar du förlorar du!
*Yoshi Island Flower Garden*
Smash like on this video to accept the challenge. If you laugh, you will lose.
Can you beat me? The grandmaster. T-the top elite of this challenge.
Bring it on! If you're not a coward then smash like right now and let's freaking do this.
Video: No, let's not leave. I wanna kill him. Wheres T-series at?? I have his stuff. T-p to him
Video: rrrrRRRAHHHHHHHH
Wait. Did they just kick him out of the game or did they kill T-series? What's the command?
Yeah, it's /kill.
*laughs* OH NOO!
Video: rrrrRRRRAAHHHHHH
Oh god. Jesus.
This is literally me when I die in video games.
Which never happens!
Zero deaths!
Video: I'm gonna shake your hand. (x2)
Video: Shake your hand
Video: I'm gonna shake your hand. I wanna shake his hand. (x2)
Video: I wanna shake his hand.
Pewds: Just shake his hand.
Video: Then force me off the fricken plane.
Pewds: He wants a handshake.
Video: I wanna shake his hand.
Video: All I wanna do. All I wanna do.
Video: You stupid son of a b*tch.
This is me when I try to shake someone's hand.
But no one wants to.
I wonder why
Video: YES! So I'm starting to uh- That was awful.
Oh ok.
Pewds: Let's freaking do this
Video: These are my hidden talents.
Oh god.
Video: I can make a lot of animal noises.
Video: I can make a baby bird. *tweet tweet tweet*
Damn.
Video: *laughs* I can make a dolphin.
Video: *Dolphin noises?*
Video: I can't get over that. Oh my god.
Video: Anyways. I can also make a cat.
Video: *failed meows*
Video: Mother- Still tryin to heal from the dolphin. *laughs*
Video: Second try
Video: *meow meow meow*
Video: My god. What am I? I can also sound like a Chihuahua.
Video: *rrrr rah rrrah rrah rrrah*
*Sad piano*
No. I'm just gonna have to use my no pass on that one.
*more sad piano*
*clap clap clap*
No one plays Fork Knife anymore since I played it. Ok?
Get with the times, losers. You still play Fork Knife?
P a t h e t i c
*A more happier piano*
WOAHHHHH
Ooh. This loops very nicely. Too bad we gotta to change the audio.
Oh!
*laughs*
Well he completely ruined everything. I don't- *laughs*
Heh. Aw, god dammit. *laughs*
AH HA HA HA
Kids. Getting. Hurt. Will. Never. Not. Be. Funny.
Oh but kids do this blah blah blah
Last again, kid will always be funny.
Especially if they're hurt.
Both: *laughing*
What are they doing?
Did he just try to read it too?
That's not funny.
Will Smith: Yuhh
Will Smith: It's rewind time.
* laughing *
Beat the challenge. Not saying the N word for an entrire- god damn
Video: Holy sh*t. Lay Back. Are you okay? *crying*
Video: That wasn't a good idea.
Oh god...
Damn!
OH!
*megolovania on piano*
God damn!
OH!
How do people do this?
Oh my god.
Video: *megolovania intensifies*
Pewds: Yeah!
You ask and you shall receive. God damn.
That's amazing, Need.iF
Huge props
*chuckles*
*music*
heh
Well I mean that's one way to do it. Oh god I've seen this.
eheh
I actually thought this was real. I was like "What?"
Frozen 2 looks amazing! I'll definitely watch it.
*Yoshi Island Flower Garden*
I don't know why that edit is so satisfying. I've seen it- I've seen it pop up everywhere now.
Video: We have right for you, Lil Uzi, a Rob Zombie poster.
*Yoshi Island!*
It's so good!
I love it.
*tries to imitate the song*
Oh god, here it goes.
*Yoshi Island*
Another one! Yes!
New meme format! Less miserable! Thank you meme! *clap clap clap clap*
Thank you.
Doesn't it feel good? You discover a meme and you just realize, "Hey look, everything is a lil better now.
Whatever you're goin' through
At least it's a little less annoying.
Video: -And then by that time like I've cut off everything else that been died.
Video: Hello Ninja, I am just confirming your order for 12 inch thick black dildo for tomorrow at 9am.
Video: Should I reschedule the order delivery for another time?
*laughs*
HAHAHAHA
People complain about MY live thing? What is this? Huh?
Imagine if I shot my videos like this.
*Yoshi Island* Oh my god!
It came back!
But even better!
*Yoshi Island*
Y e s
*Yoshi Island again*
Alright, it's already running a little dry. I dunno what to tell you guys.
*laughs* Come on! Come on, do it!
D o i t ! ! !
Video: YEAH BOIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIII
Pewds: Oh! No! Oh god!
What happened to my lights? Delgad- AAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHH
I'm blind!
I need help!
Oh real bad. Ah!
Ah.
Is this from Yoshi? No. No it isn't. It- it still works.
*Yoshi Island*
That reminds me of that tweet from that guy.
YouTuber guy.
Should have said 12, clearly not a good tweet. Try again.
Alright. Um
Video: So if you're attracted to Ariana Grande. She's 23 years old. Sure.
Video: But she looks like a 12 year old! No! Yeah, a little bit. She's a 12 year old wearing her mom's makeup!
Pewds: She does look weird.
Video: That does look like a child... Look she's even standing like a baby. *laughs*
Pewds: *laughs*
Video: That's not a baby stance! That's a baby stance! Are you crazy?
Video: She like, "I want apple!" *laughs*
Evreyone: *laughing*
Oh that was great.
She does look like a 12 year old.
It's f**king weird
*Yoshi Island* That's it! Oh yeah! Oh yeah! Okay!
Hope you guys enjoyed this video. Whatever this dance is.
*Yoshi Island playing over Pewds*
-Tuber Simulator is now so relevant...
That its got a brand new minigame! Craniac.
Drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine-like game.
And you say there's more? Of course there is!
New knowledge perks. New quests. And new pixellinks. And legs.
Guys...
L e g s
Megolovania!!!!
[I hope you fellow 9 year olds have a great day or night!]